all right let's go over to our
correspondent Alexander fund Naaman who
has been listening in to president Trump
speech at the United Nations in New York
Alexandra and not your usual
run-of-the-mill type of a speech that we
heard from President Trump let's play at
the beginning of that speech in less
than two years my administration has
accomplished more than almost any
Administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
all right some slight note of relief
there the UN General Assembly bursting
out and laughter quite remarkable on a
serious note though how did his speech
go down well I think that it was quite
unusual for the international audience
here to listen to this opening and it
was quite an unusual way to start a
speech on an international stage with
remarks like these touting one's
personal economic accomplishments for us
reporters who covered the White House
however I have to say that it's not
unusual that's what we see on a daily
basis that the president uses every
occasion to talk about his
accomplishments but for the audience
here it was obviously unusual therefore
we saw that too this opening remarks
were met with laughter now Alexander on
North Korea which was also the focus of
his speech last year he referred to the
leader of that country as rocket man on
a suicide mission this year he addressed
him as honorable friend quite a change
within just a year at least in rhetoric
yes indeed you write Leyla
lasya was he reporting on the
president's first speech and as you said
he called Kim Jong Hyun a rocket man on
a suicide mission and now he is
describing him as an honorable man so
what a change what a shift from threats
to flattery and we have to say that
there is fresh hope that progress is
being made in talks with North Korea
because the country has pledged to
dismantle one of its missile test site
and his major nuclear site however we
also have to say that we haven't seen
yet any evidence that the North Korean
regime
it's really committed to complete
denuclearization but then of course no
warming of relations with foe Iran yes
and I would even say that President
Trump doubled down on Iran accusing is
it of accusing the Iranian regime of
sowing death destruction and cares but
he also made a very clear distinction in
his speech a distinction between the
Iranian regime and the Iranian people he
called upon all the nations gathered
here to support the Iranian people so
that seems to be a strategy here
of course many critics of the Trump
administration will say that its goal is
to bring about a regime change in Iran
but that is something that the Trump
administration has strongly denied and
Alexandre in the closing a president
Trump's America first policy we're at
the heart of his address at the UN who
was the intended audience well I think
that in this case he was addressing very
clearly to the American people and most
of all his supporters as we know we are
only a few weeks away from very
important midterm elections in which the
Democrats are in the lead according to
the latest polls so they have a good
chance to win back the house and that is
of course something that Donald Trump
doesn't want to see and therefore he was
addressing his domestic audience
reassuring his supporters that he is
sticking to his america-first policy and
that he is the one who deserves credit
for America's a growing economy DW is
Alexander phenomenal reporting from the
UN in New York thank you